ah
[Música]
en los eeuu aumenta cada vez más el
número de jóvenes entre 18 y 34 años que
continúan viviendo con sus padres pero
esto es inusual ya que aquí en este país
los jóvenes dejan sus hogares a los 18 ó
20 años en promedio cuando se gradúan de
la escuela secundaria o high school y
van acudes a la universidad o comienzan
sus vidas de manera independiente sin
embargo la pandemia es la que ha causado
que muchos jóvenes tuvieran que regresar
de las universidades hacer cuarentena en
las casas de sus padres otra de las
razones es el desempleo más de 20
millones de personas en los eeuu han
pedido subsidios por el desempleo y ésta
ha sido una de las razones por las
cuales estos jóvenes o adultos han
comenzado a regresar a las casas de sus
padres
[Música]
y tal es uno de los pocos países en
europa en el cual es corriente que los
jóvenes se queden viviendo en la casa de
sus padres pasados los 30 años se estima
que en la península más del 64 por
ciento de los jóvenes entre los 18 y los
34 años todavía viven en la casa de sus
padres varios factores explican esta
situación primero el factor económico
sobre todo en el sur del país en donde
es particularmente difícil para los
jóvenes encontrar un empleo estable y
así pues es complicado independizarse
pero también está el factor cultural
muchas familias son apegadas y no logran
cortar el cordón umbilical seguramente
esta crisis de el coronavirus no va a
mejorar esta situación va a agudizar
este fenómeno ya que el país se encamina
hacia la crisis económica más grave
desde la segunda guerra mundial
[Música]
según datos de eurostat los jóvenes
portugueses son de los que más tardan en
salir de casa de sus padres la edad
promedio 29 años cuando la edad promedio
en la unión europea es de 26 algunos son
los factores que inciden entre ellos
culturales mercado inmobiliario y
contexto laboral según un estudio de la
fundación gulbenkian ya para 2017 más
del 63 por ciento de los jóvenes entre
18 y 34 años vivían con sus padres y
según los especialistas esta podría ser
una generación más afectada que las dos
anteriores debido a las consecuencias
que ha traído la pandemia un informe más
reciente de una de las principales
inmobiliarias del país arroja que cuatro
de cada diez jóvenes en portugal no
tienen la capacidad de emanciparse más
del 38 por ciento no tiene el
rendimiento regular y más del 57 por
ciento tiene una remuneración líquida
menor a mil euros a esto se le aúna que
el mercado inmuebles va en alza ha sido
la tendencia en los últimos años incluso
en el primer semestre de este año ha
registrado un alza del 8% pese a la
pandemia
[Música]